here's what would happen if a
gravitational wave hit earth
gravitational waves are caused by the
Collision of black holes supernovae or
even remnants of gravitational radiation
from The Big Bang
these waves travel at the speed of
gravity which is equal to the speed of
light if Earth was hit by one of these
gravitational ripples we would likely
look a little bit more like IO one of
Jupiter's moons our landscape would be
covered in lava and Volcanic Fallout
with an atmosphere made up of toxic
gases like hydrogen sulfide the result
would be massive global warming and
intense storms now luckily even though
we do get hit by some gravitational
waves they're generally so small that we
don't feel any impact count your
blessings that we're nowhere near any
massive objects shooting out larger
gravitational waves because